えー　バナナ
間違えて１８００本買ったんですけど
ちょっと多いかな　と　と　多かった
ちょうど食べごろなんですよ
も、シュガースポットが最高においしい
食べる時期の旬まで来ちゃってるんですけど…
あ、ここは俺たち用ね('ω')
これは俺用です、俺用。（大事なことなので2回言いました）
これだけでも 全然100本超えてるんですよ
いや、これが結構深刻な悩みで～
バナナって生もの何で
なんかその、友達とか家族とか後輩とか
なんかこう
知り合いの人に渡すのは全然いいんですけど～
知らない人に渡して、
もし体調崩しちゃったり、体調崩しちゃったり、
なんか変な食中毒とか、
虫とか入ってたり
ポックリいっちゃたりしたら、
僕が殺したことになるんですよ( ;∀;)
1800本流石に僕の周りの人で完全に配れなかったんですよ…
という訳で、バナナは
捨てませーーん
バナナは捨てません
誰にも渡せない
という訳で、実はですねあのー
動物園の人に～
連絡を取りまして、
そちらの動物園にバナナ好きな方
いませんか。と連絡したところ、
亀さんが食べてくれるみたいで、
5日くらい経ってても全然いいよー↗
みたいなことを園長さんに言われたので
今から動物園の人にバナナを1800本届けに行ってきます！
では行こう！!(^^)!
え、絶対無理じゃん
うぅんん(@_@)
だぁぁぁぁ( ﾟДﾟ)
（OK)
はい！という訳で、荷物を積め込みが終わったんで、
早速、
動物園の園長のところに向かおうと思います。( ;∀;)
では
はーくしょん(ノД`)・゜・。
凄いよ反響いつもいつも
すごいねほんとに
本当ですか？
すごい！
はい、という訳でIZoooの園長さんです！
はい、こんにちは～(888888
すいません。とてもバナナが大量に余ってしまったんで…
園長も食べるんですねｗｗ
どんな動物が食べるんですか？(';')
えっと、IZooの一番食べるのは、ゾウガメ
ゾウガメかぁ(;´･ω･)
うん。ゾウガメだったら、
30本40本は1頭辺りは食べるので、
うち、70頭以上いるので、
ははははｗｗ一瞬ｗｗ
そう、一瞬になるかもしれない
えー是非是非
今ちょうど食べごろだと思うんで
そうですね。喜ぶと思いますよ
食べますか。この子は
蛇は食べない
バナナみたいな色してるけど。('_')
ぁぁぁぁ、
可愛い可愛い可愛い
バナナ食べるんじゃない？
え？ほんとですか？
どうしたどうした
食べさしていいですか
はい。バナナ
超嫌がってるｗｗ
食べないの？
うわ、凄い嫌じゃん
食べないじゃないかｗ（モグモグ
この子食べるよ、バナナ
あ、あ、食べた食べた
凄い凄い
俺のバナナがｗｗ
バナナ好物。
あ、そうなんだ
俺のバナナが…(´・ω・`)
バナナよ～♡
はははｗくそｗ
近づけたら目瞑るんだよな
バナナよ～♡
おっ！
ちょっと近づけて。口の先に
♪
あははｗｗおいおいおいｗｗｗ
あ、凄い凄い
あっ！
やってみよう
やってみます！
そうそう、いいよ、そのくらい取ったら大丈夫
後は自分で食いちぎるから
バ、バナナよ～♡
ぱぁ～( ﾟДﾟ)
あ、めっちゃあなただけ食べるのね
うをぉぉ
おぉぉ
あうっ！ああああ　ははｗｗｗ
飛び掛かり食いされちゃった
ぉおぉぉ
持ってきます。早速
お願いします。
せーのっ！よいっ！
あ、有難うございます
これで全部です。
全部？
はい…
ほんとにいいんですか。こんな量で
という訳で有難うございます。
有難うございます
助かります
ウミガメの餌にしてやってくださいっ
ウミガメじゃない。ゾウガメ！
あっゾウガメの餌にｗｗｗ…（やらかした…）
という訳で、
えーと僕の、
バナナを食べてるウミガメは、
IZooという…
ゾウガメ。
あっへへへｗｗｗ（やらかした…）
僕のバナナを食べてるゾウガメは、
IZooという
いずの動物園にいるので、
是非皆さん、見に来てやってくださいっ
バナナ…処理できないと炎上してたんで
また、近々遊びにくるんで。
はい。また。
有難うございます！
有難うございます
さぁ、ウミガメに会いに行くぞー
ゾウガメ。
ゾウガメね